all right one more quick Trump story
we've really relegated the Trump stuff
to like the back pages of the show
lately Donald Trump again has posted
captured to truth Central cat turd is a
Twitter account right leaning I don't
know who runs it it's all nonsense Trump
posting a captured poll the poll asked
who will get second place in the
Republican primary
Ron DeSantis or Vivek ramaswamy in this
poll Vivek ramaswamy will according to
the voters two-thirds of those who voted
on this say that Vivek ramaswamy will
end up in second place in the Republican
primary and only about one-thirds say
that Ron DeSantis will end up in second
place in the Republican primary this is
all meant to attack Ron DeSantis now if
you look at actual polling the numbers
are very different according to polling
Vivek ramaswamy is polling 2.4 percent
whereas Ron DeSantis has like eight
times that level of support at 21 so if
we look at anything that is
evidence-based anything empirical
it doesn't appear as though Vivek
ramaswamy is going to Surge and surpass
Ron DeSantis but we know that the real
numbers never really mattered to these
people interestingly I do want to just
point out a little bit there's not been
any major polling shift for several
weeks which is why I've not been talking
about polling but in looking at these
numbers what you might see is that
dating back to June 20th there's been a
little bit of an uptick again for Donald
Trump and a little bit of a downswing
for Ron DeSantis although again big
picture if you zoom out and you go back
to Trump's first arrest uh Trump has
been very steady in the low 50s and Ron
DeSantis was has been very steady right
around 21. nobody else really making any
move
other than Mike Pence who has seen a
surge from roughly four to six it's an
explosive six
trust me but it is still only six what
is the uh what what is responsible for
that quite frankly I have no idea six is
still not going to get you particularly
far
one of our sponsors is yada the Free
banking app that makes it fun to save
money just like a regular bank account
you can withdraw your money anytime and
it's fully FDIC insured when you keep
your money in a yada bank account you'll
have a shot at winning nightly cash
prizes ranging from two cents to a
million dollars for every twenty five
dollars in your account you get one
recurring ticket to the nightly prize
drawing so if you deposit a hundred
dollars you get four tickets every
single night without needing to make any
more deposits yada also offers some
great budgeting features the possibility
of early paydays a debit card that
rewards you with up to one hundred
percent cash back and tickets on every
purchase yata members have already won
over 15 million dollars so say goodbye
to the traditional savings account with
the minimal interest rate free economics
have described prize linked savings
accounts like a no lose Lottery download
the app now start saving for a chance to
win big with yada the app where savings
meets excitement go to with yada.com
Pacman the link is in the description